asians cover 60 of the world's
population
we don't even see anything close to that
on screen not even close
there was that false notion that they
would question like
well are asian people gonna watch this
and it's like
you know what i've been watching white
people my whole life
i would get asked to do an accent and
then i would say okay
and then i would go in and i wouldn't do
it i feel confident that
i am just as funny if not funnier so i
will because i'm not
feeling also deep shame while i'm doing
this now we are doing
it ourselves and so once you start
writing producing
then you have more control and that's
what i think is so wonderful about you
three
um you know you're writers you know
you're comedians you're telling your own
story you
and um i'm getting chills because i'm
saying no i have to say my own words too
now and start to put myself out there
all right well first of all i just want
to thank you guys all so much for
joining us for this panel you know the
goal for us
was obviously to amplify api voices and
to uplift the community see how you guys
are using your platforms to do that i
also want to show people just how
diverse
the asian community is that it's not
monolithic and so i felt like we should
kick things off by maybe going around
saying who we are in name in what we do
an inheritance genie do you wanna kick
things off for us
so i always think asian american parents
if you have your child who is
into the arts into writing into
producing into film directing
encourage them my name is jeannie mai
i'm a television personality i'm an
advocate
against human trafficking and of course
to protect the aapi community
and i'm just really happy to be here
thank you for repping the aapi community
and
happy heritage month to us and everybody
else is celebrating i told my mother
when i was 14
i wanted to be a comedian and she said
oh maybe
it's better if you just die
i'm margaret cho i'm korean and chinese
i am comedian i'm an actor the activist
a musician a writer and a pet parent
now tell me this if i send an email
where would i put the stamp
hi i'm massa valli i am indian and i'm
an actor and a comedian and a writer
my parents set me up with the son of a
business associate he's going to be a
doctor
how old is he 16 so he's going to be a
doctor in 100 years
well my parents like to plan ahead hi
i'm keiko aguenna
and i am an actress and i wrote a book a
couple years ago as well
and i am officially okinawan american
100
but usually i go by japanese because
that's the um
uh the nation of japan but uh if we're
going to get specific i'll i'll
put a little knock on there for okinawa
love it
this is where the real party is okay
all right well i'm danny directo i'm a
host and senior producer over at et
digital and
not gonna lie i'm a mixed bag but that
also includes being filipino so i'm a
proud proud
member of the aapi community um and you
know obviously you guys we have seen
a lot of aapi coverage be either
negative or critical especially right
now so i actually wanted to start our
entire conversation by
asking what makes you most proud about
being asian
i think it's our resilience yeah it's
it's like our resilience in the face of
this adversity we've been a
big part of america since 1849
and yet we have wasted so many eras
of anti-asian american racism
and yet still come back and stayed here
stayed with it and i'm really proud of
that
there's there's no story greater than
how
all of our parents and our parents
parents
got here there's always a stat a story
of triumph of
struggle of some type of exchange of
assimilating
of having to become american
and have to endure so much more racism
um that has
obviously continued and when i think
about what my parents
and my parents parents have gone through
i feel so privileged today
i feel so honored because i mean they
paved the road for me i'm not climbing
on a boat with 13 other people to get
here i'm not
you know trying to figure out the
language to get my citizenship
so truly my parents allow me to learn
what being fearless is like
and through that i've really learned
what being vietnamese
means for me i think i'm really proud of
asian americans um not only my
in the past but also at this present
moment i feel like there's an energy and
electricity and a need to connect
it is a challenge because we are so
different our
the asian-american identity is really an
umbrella
that kind of is over a lot of us but our
our individual family experiences are
very different and so this desire to
be vulnerable and share our stories and
and put ourselves out there to connect
with other people in the asian american
community is something to be admired and
i admire
the people that are doing that now i
think it's just you know that sense of
community
and heritage and understanding of your
own privilege
and where you are now because of other
people's sacrifices
and the continuing sort of progression
as a community to try to
accomplish more and and be more seen and
heard and
inclusive and represented i think is um
just what lies ahead i think i'm really
excited about
um you know before we talk about the
future i do want to look at the past
particularly about your guys's personal
stories let's start with margaret what
was life like growing up for you
i think what it is is that i never saw
asian american faces or
heard their stories on television and so
you really feel invisible
so when i started in the entertainment
industry it was really kind of
starting out like wondering if it was
even possible
asian americans have now really forged a
path in entertainment
we've had to sort of create of nothing
because we didn't exist at all anywhere
not only were you growing up asian but
you're also growing up queer
and i'm curious how that what that
intersection looked like for you you
know was there ever a time that you felt
like
the minority within the minority
yes for sure but i think that with
queerness there
was so much great uh examples
of growing up in san francisco so i got
to see
gay lifestyle sort of modeled in a way
that was really
inspiring and incredible and so you know
growing up also during the aids crisis
there was a real
need to look to identity as a kind of a
life-saving
gesture so in a lot of ways um the
violence towards the gay community
during the aids epidemic reminds me of
the violence towards the asian american
community now during
coronavirus and so people are using
the fear and anger about the disease
as an excuse to act out violence around
biases they
already have so it's not really the
disease it's really the disease of
racism
you know genie you tell personal stories
for a living and
in an interview with us actually with et
you said your mom encouraged you to
speak out and that she didn't want you
to be a quiet
asian can you speak to those stereotypes
and how they
might have impacted you yes i'm really
thankful
that mama my really made my identity
something to celebrate as part of my
personality whereas some of my other
relatives were like learn to speak
english
get to to move like them dress like them
because if you don't they're going to
continue
looking at us like we're weird and what
they meant was that they'll look at us
like foreigners you know in the bay area
where in front
there was a word called fob thrown
around and it was like a bad thing to be
a fob you know if you wore flip-flops if
you looked like you didn't speak english
you look like you didn't get it you
couldn't dance immediately you were you
were
you know removed from the cool kids so
there were parts of me that were super
asian like
i think vietnamese food is the best food
no shade everybody
no shade but i think i think our boom
our fa our kumchi reigns supreme and so
i would eat it but i would eat it in
like the privacy of my home because
there was a lot of fragrances to it that
i
i knew would offend people because my
family would make it so i
they would just make it like be careful
that's made of fish sauce or the shrimp
paste so it's gonna embarrass people
don't eat that in front of kids so here
i was
trying to go get a lunchable when i
really wanted my bunny sandwich that my
mom would make me you know
so even though i thought being asian was
cool as far as like
being able to speak another language or
looking different because a lot of the
kids around my school were either white
black or hispanic
i still remember now that i did hide
some things because i was like be asian
because you're unique but don't be too
much because you're going to scare
people
and don't show that you've got like 15
people living in our house
you know my parents sponsored like all
the other um
family members that weren't able to
escape over and so we had
15 people living in the three-bedroom
home
hi are you amy yes great i'm jeannie
from character fantasy hey
oh my gosh i built my name on just being
genie my
and that includes my heritage my culture
and all the things my mom had been
telling me when i was young
but i didn't yet embrace it in totality
until today now i'm doing youtube videos
about how to make the most pungent
vietnamese food so you're not getting it
watered down
the soup of our people
[Applause]
this is the first time i'm actually
feeling in a culmination of all of us
really awakening to what our culture
means because we
have that camaraderie before and and
that's not to blame it on anybody it's
just that
now we're really waking up to it how
much of that though is also because you
really didn't have a choice either you
know
you're not playing a character you're
playing you you are you in everything
you do
do you feel like being asian has now
become like your superpower
absolutely that's that's my superpower
today is really just being exactly me
i was gonna say i think that makes all
of us the power rangers then we're
forces combined
okay we're gonna take on the world i
love it also how did your upbringing
kind of shape
you or also shape the path that you
chose
similarly i mean i grew up in um in
arizona and it was just you know my my
parents just went there because my dad
got a job there so the rest of my family
was
in like chicago wisconsin it was it was
fine i mean
you know a lot of things that when you
grow up you don't realize
until you leave i remember i got freaked
out
like the first time i went to chicago i
was at a stop sign and i was waiting
across the street
and i felt weird and it was because it
was the first time in my life
there were like 15 indian people around
me that i wasn't related to
so it kind of made me realize like oh
man i really missed out on so much
you know kind of gave me a different
perspective on you know a lot of
uh comedy i feel like sometimes is like
from people who feel like they're on the
outside looking in
and uh i definitely i definitely
use that as a fuel to to work on my
on my craft i'm a great uncle um i don't
know if you can tell um i have a very
energetic
uh here let's play legos vibe about me
um
but i recently ruined my nephew's uh
birthday party
because i'm an adult and i use logic and
he's seven
and it's been really cool also coming up
at the time that i did to be
um in this sort of wave of all these
other people who
you know look like me or sound like me
to come out and be like yeah
you know much akin to what margot was
saying of like you know i remember
me and my friends pitched our sketch
show
in like 2000 you know maybe 13-14
and we went into meetings and it's the
same thing that got made into a special
later years later
but people were just like who's gonna
watch this who's the audience that would
always be the thing who's what is this
who's this for
and then you know like five years later
for them to come beg us can you go can
you please make that thing for us
so those kinds of like you know
everything always feels like it's moving
too slowly but
especially like in in in that kind of a
world but
i definitely see like oh things are like
gradually
kind of moving forward unfortunately in
entertainment it's always like
hey we can make some money here please
make your thing
um well yeah there was that false notion
that
they would question like well are asian
people
gonna watch this and it's like you know
what i've been watching white people
my whole life right like why would they
think that
like we're so much like oh we only watch
ourselves if we we did that we would
never
be able to watch any because there were
very few images of asians doing anything
so it's really ridiculous how racist
things have to be for them to sort of
like
shift and acknowledge like oh okay it's
not only for asian people you know it's
like for everybody but i'm loving this
i'm loving this so much keiko i'm going
to toss it to you i'm curious
i want to hear about your upbringing as
well but also what was your parents
or family's reaction when you told them
i want to be an actor
well my family was supported
i know that's uh not the normal asian
response
i actually have the opposite of growing
situation than awesome actually because
i grew up in hawaii
which is majority asian american and my
parents
were very relaxed they never cared about
my grades at all
i was completely comfortable and thought
i could play
any role because that's just the way it
was growing up in the theater
uh scene there until i got to college
and that's when i had the rude awakening
of
you don't get to play anything just
anything now
you know i i was i was auditioning for
something i forget the name of the play
but
it was three british women in the 1800s
and it wasn't until i was standing in
front of the callback board and my name
wasn't on it that it
that it then dawned on me at age 18 so
late
that it might possibly be because
because i'm asian
and so that was the whole transition to
bring my naivety in line with
with reality lucy lou
recently reflected on why her role in
charlie's angels was
so meaningful to her and it's because
she got to play a person who happened to
be
asian and not an asian person and i
imagine
all of you can relate uh what has been
your take on that sort of casting
experience in general
okay go i'll start with you actually oh
yeah it because the roles that i've
taken have been
a little bit of a mix so i i don't know
if they're exactly
they're probably 50 50 as far as number
wise not as far as time wise because
gilmore girls was much longer as far as
time
um i kind of love i i personally kind of
like it
when it's not necessarily written um
asian specific but i know not everybody
feels that way i don't know how other
people feel
i think it's great any i'll take
anything i mean i'm like fine with
whatever it
i'm just is to work i am you know it's
hard because it's like
you just really kind of have to take
what's given in a sense because there's
not
there's i mean there's more but there's
still not a lot out there and so i end
up creating my own
stuff i i just like have to say hi to
the asian people
i think stand-up comedians have an
advantage because we have
that side of our work that we can always
go to right
awesome you have a very impressive imdb
i mean you've
been a part of many different projects
so i'm curious what has your casting
experience been like
um you know it's sort of like i
understand both
both well both sides uh that's such a
negative thing to say nowadays but i
understand both sides of of like you
know people want to go out for things
that are
you know in an ideal world all the parts
are written you know
for anybody to play and anybody can can
get them
and i also understand that you know
there are some specific stories that
need to be told or and and you know you
want to see both of those things you
want to see like
you know i would love to be on it's
always something in philadelphia and
just be
a jackass i would love i would love to
do that and
you know i could see myself being on
something like that and then also
but you also value um
you know movies or tv shows that are
like specific
and you're like oh this is also great
because it talks about a specific
experience that that
person or that group of people can
identify with and then
through that everybody can watch and see
how other people live
and get something from that but as as
far as my own like just my own
trajectory a lot of it would usually be
this has happened actually a lot more
than uh
i would like to admit it always like it
surprises other
indian american actors i would get asked
to do an accent and then i would say
okay and then i would go in and i
wouldn't do it
and that was just my balls in just being
like
hey man i'm gonna tell you because i
know you're the casting person and i
know you need to tell me this because
this is your you need to say this
but i'm going to go in there and i'm
going to not do it
and i feel confident that i am just as
funny
if not funnier so i will because i'm not
feeling also
deep shame while i'm doing this right so
i'm gonna do it and be funny
and then you know they'll laugh you have
that that their laughs are on tape
you can't erase that so then you have to
live with this now
you have to be like hey we forced all
these other people who do not
speak naturally within an accent nor is
the like the problem with the accent
thing for me is not
i don't want to do one it's nine times
out of ten it's in lieu of the writing
actually being funny
so it's like hey this this character
isn't funny
so how can we make it funny if he says i
want to go to a store but has an indian
accent then
that will make people laugh right and
that's just like i'm not going to
entertain
your laziness so that was like a thing
that i was like really like i would
always
do that and also with like agents and
stuff they would sometimes
be like you know a little short-sighted
in that they'd be like oh do
like because when i was starting up a
lot of like the terrorist things were
very in vogue at the time so they're
like oh go do that or do this
because there's this saying that like
work begets work
and unfortunately that only really
benefits um
like white people because like um white
people are allowed to have range
people of color are not really allowed
to have rank you're just like a lot of
friends who were
of color and they would you know they
they were like much more like
well trained than like juilliard people
and they would come
and they would do like a terrorist world
three times because they're just trying
to like get into the business
and then they would have to leave
because they're like every time i go in
then for like a friend
or a husband or some other person they
would just flip over your thing and
your resume and be like oh but why would
we ever do that
you're clearly just the terrorist guy
and thankfully i had stand up so they're
like hey man if you can go make enough
money to survive
go do that and just try to hold out as
long
as you possibly can and just do these
other roles so then
just weeding those out i would then try
to just do worlds that were not
so heavily dependent on those kinds of
negative
specifically negative uh stereotypes and
then through that
you know just working and doing that
plus doing stand-up and making your own
stuff
um helped me helped me a lot negative
stereotypes withstanding
i'm curious for everyone here when was
the first time that you felt
that you were represented on screen i
haven't
you haven't i haven't unless it's my own
work i haven't
no i mean it that we haven't gotten that
i mean for me
as a queer older asian american woman
no only my stand-up has but i have hope
it's interesting that margaret said that
because um i kind of feel that way
that way too even though i um
i know there have been asian uh uh women
before
before i i came up but i i still don't
feel viscerally
that way i don't and so coming up
i really looked to people in my life i
looked to the teachers that were in my
life that those were the people that
inspired me
and then i just went week to week you
know i it was just
really um for most of my early career
it's just survival mode so it doesn't
matter whether it's television or
theater or class
or anything i'm just trying to
connect with people in this box called
acting and i was just trying to do it as
much as i could
not even thinking that we would have the
kind of things that are happening right
now
just listening to everybody here on the
panel speak you're making me think about
some of the some of my beginnings and
and how
it got me to where i am right now
because i remember if you look at my
imdb
you'll see the first few rows of my
shows
were all like the sexy sidekick i
always was the chick who had no lines
and i was standing next to my white main
co-host
and i was the one that was really
stressed and i would just be like
you know vanna whiting the situation and
for some reason
there's a lot of car shows in there and
i know nothing about cars
right and i realize now that i was how
else are you going to trick people to
buy ikea
right well if you knew my people would
only be involved in
buying honda civics so actually there
were civics around us
but no i realized that i was a part of
that
that ongoing thing that hollywood is
legendary for which is
just stimulating stereotypes like taking
stereotypes of people and just like
banging them into the ground like of
what we constantly see whether it's a
doctor
played by an asian on tv or a hot sexy
vixen or
you know a soft lotus flower demure
asian girl or whatever it may be in
and so for me i had no speaking roles
and i remember there was a job finally
that i got
where i was reading um it was
entertainment news
and i was reading the teleprompter of
news of like crazy salacious things
where i had to comment and plus i'm like
very opinionated
so every time i commented i literally
got told by my boss like
don't insert opinion just read what
you're saying and
my coat my main host was getting the
lines he was getting
to say the the comments or he would take
some of mine i left that job
and i don't know what happened in me
that just kind of
woke up but i just started really over
it's almost like when something happens
to you so you oversteer the opposite
direction
i just started really being super
opinionated everywhere everywhere i was
hosting i was always like what's my
opinion about this award i'm presenting
what's my opinion about this environment
in this show what's my opinion on every
audition i did i i always injected
opinion
i had to build that path to show that
i'm an asian-american woman
who doesn't do math well who
doesn't always just date asians who
doesn't believe all these asian
stereotypes when you ask about
representation today
asians cover 60 of the world's
population
we don't even see anything close to that
on screen not even close
but the last things i've seen with asian
american faces
um emerging is two more reality shows
that are themed after either being crazy
or rich
like house of hoe and bling empire and
then more
asian women faces being into the
franchises of
real housewives or wives of medicine so
again either crazy or rich
and that's all coming from thank god
right
crazy rich asians which was the last big
you know office buff blowout that like
made us go okay we're not just joy look
club and we're not just martial artists
now we're crazy and rich so thank god
for yes like asian leads and like
henry golding and daniel d kim i can't
help but think about gilmore girls too
with keiko i mean keigo your character
elaine kim
you know was one of very few asian
characters on network television
for a long time uh i'm curious looking
back like what are your thoughts on
that and also what is your relationship
to that character now
uh well with separation my my thoughts
about her now
um i'm much more protective of her
now like at the time like i said i was
just in survival mode i wasn't thinking
about anything
but now when i think about her i sort of
wish something
better for her i mean like if if we if
if lane kim kept living and it's now you
know in her
imaginary world also 2021 i kind of hope
that she just
has a breakdown and tells zach and her
mom to co-parent her kids
and then she just does something for
herself
i think she did everything for everybody
else you know she was very
subservient to her mom and she was uh
she became a wife and a mother very
early
and she was the best friend she was the
you know selfless
uh someone else's um you know
best friend i don't know that's that's
how i feel about her now it's not how i
felt about it
i kind of think that extreme is funny
and maybe i'm in the minority in this
but um i hope we don't only get
asian characters that are well balanced
like i want to see
the freaking nutty person that that
believes so strongly in something that
it's detrimental to their lives that's
fun to play and it's fun to watch
so i don't mind that
that relationship i think that's a fun
relationship i think the only problem is
that's maybe
the only relationship we see
so or one of the few dynamics that we
had tend to see of this tiger mom
stereotype so
um it would be better if we just had
other you know if this wheel was 360. so
we saw a lot of different
uh players populations and relationships
absolutely
you know um also if you were talking
earlier about how
there was that whole terrorist
stereotype and those roles that existed
and then i also feel like for people of
color
a lot of times in the past they were
cast as the villain or the other you
know
and with your wanda vision uh background
in mind how do you feel studios like
marvel and disney
are embracing diversity now um i think
they're seeing that with the success of
you know black panther and all they're
just seeing that there are
so many people i'm sure on their end
it's like a creative thing
and you know they have all this source
material to to go to work from
um but purely from like a financial
sense it's it's it's just like good
business
there's 60 60 jeanne said there's 60 of
of of the world is why wouldn't you show
them that like
um like my family's indian we would
watch a lot of bollywood movies and
bollywood movies are like second to uh
american movies as the most
watched and there's like i would be you
know in i remember i did a show
in uh minneapolis and uh the
guy driving me was uh somalian and he
was like
obsessed with bollywood movies
[Music]
he told me about all the actors and if i
knew and i like felt bad because i did
my knowledge of bollywood moves was not
as up to par as his
so it's just like there is such a need
in and
to see these kinds of big movies too
because a lot of the movies that we make
that are
you know um specific and like they make
them into like
niche like this is a niche story about
you know this asian family
that only like 12 people will watch but
it'll win an award right
the movies that they'll see across the
world are like these
big tentpole you know you're fast and
furious or your black pant like he's big
so to see that in like a marvel thing
seeing diversity in something that's so
big
and that will be seen by truly the whole
world i think is is like
really great and and i think what marvel
is doing with that of like genuinely
pushing it and not
forcing it by being like hey we have
this actual source material let's do
this and they have such a
well-proven system that they can just
plug and play things and
make things great you're fine you're all
you're all going to be
fine you let us sleep we have your
nightmares
it was just fun for me to be a part and
see how that works and it was really
cool
to see where it's going and to see all
these awesome projects that are being
made
and i think you know even when i went to
india
you know to see my cousins and and do
some shows they were those were the
shows that they were most excited about
you know they're not like hey we saw the
criterion collection like that's awesome
but they're like hey we're 14. we want
to see something that's
you know huge and big and there's one
anywhere
they're not going anywhere hey the music
isn't bothering you is it pal
in terms of distraction from work or the
largely nonsensical nature of the lyrics
the first one so even to do like one
division like i'm by no means like
the lead of the show but to even see how
many people reached out to me about
that it just showed how much of like a
um
a desire and a want there is by
the rest of the world to be seen in
these kinds of like
bigger sort of fun productions it's
literally like
diego luna he's like i'm a mexican
innocent yeah crazy and amazing thing
yeah i get it well listen guys obviously
it's aapi heritage month but i
also want to shed a light on what's
going on in the world particularly of
course the rise of asian hate
how are you doing how are your families
doing i kind of want to kick this to
margaret
and jeannie first because you guys are
both from the san francisco bay area
where for
a minute there it was the epicenter of
this violence um
how are you guys feeling about it it's
really terrible
i think it's really scary it doesn't
seem to be abating
actually it seems to be um accelerating
and
it i i mean i think it's it's just
terrifying
and it's it's not i i don't
understand it anymore and that i can
feel like the the but what is great is
the
community has really come together to
help people what's sad
is they're really targeting elders which
is really
very painful and um really hard to take
so hopefully there'll be an end to it
but at least we are coming together
and trying to stop it i agree with you
especially since margaret you know
the bae is truly an example of a melting
pot there's not one
you know overall race there's an area
where indian people just like
be killing it out there and koreans and
chinese vietnamese black puerto rican
dominican it's it's everything and you
can see it in the kids
when you walk through the bay no kid is
just one race there's a lot of mixed
race kids and it's really beautiful
um i actually was having a call with my
team today because
i was so exasperated and
and i'm i'm desperate because i'm from
the bay and i've done a million of these
like these speaking engagements margaret
you and i have crossed paths like
three or four times that yeah how many
times have you sat there reading the
script
saying stop aap like raising money for
gofundme the whole thing i've done it
all
and just last week in mission bay a 36
year old man
so he's younger than me a 36 year old
man
was beaten in the middle of the street
while his one-year-old
went it was in a stroller and just kind
of like like
floated off into the street because his
father his father wasn't able to go
there and stop him as he was getting
beat in the ground
um the crimes are continuing president
biden already addressed this
um as we know um almost a month ago now
the flag was lowered half mass
nothing ceased nothing nothing has
stopped
and so i'm throwing this out there to
you guys um my friends like what i don't
know what we can do
i don't know what to do at this point
because this is not working i've been
doing this since last march
when homeboy was calling us the kung flu
virus when he was
calling us like you know we were the we
were the reason for the whole flu so
now anybody with slanted eyes is up for
open season like anybody
you're all a target it doesn't matter
anymore you don't have to be old
well i think what we saw with the me too
movement and the black lives matter
movement is that
the community itself cannot do it alone
like we need the collective here you
know we need allies and so we obviously
have this platform right now so i'll
just ask how can
allies support the community right now
do you guys think it's just getting up
and talking about it
you know whether it's the atlanta
shootings whether it's the shootings in
indiana at fedex you know where
i think four sikh people were killed out
of all
all of these crimes are hate crimes and
you know to
acknowledge that this has to stop
and it's not just like asian people are
only going to watch asian entertainment
it's like the world has to get
in the middle of it everybody has to
roll their sleeves up and get into this
so
people who have the ability to
um showcase our stories let our stories
be heard
like what you're doing here danny i mean
i'm i'm so proud of et
i think you know i've definitely run
across um et's
um waves a few times and we've always
talked about entertainment news i've
never seen us talk about
asian um history i don't think we've
talked about the racism
i've never been a part of a conversation
like this huge ever yeah
but i also know okay that it takes
somebody
to have that to have that narrative to
have that
to feel that need to do that so a we
need more diversity
within these positions of power we need
more people that look like us that look
like people of color not just us but
black brown
everything across the board so that we
can actually see the representation
and then we need more people to speak up
so something's also happening with
humanity where we're getting
desensitized from seeing
people being being victimized and hurt
so
people need to speak up people need to
stop being afraid for themselves
and i think consequences need to take
place i think
we this is where legislation has to
change and
this is where we have to
take control of our voting power in
order to get in there and
fill in uh the those positions of power
with more
more faces of color and also there's so
many things that we could be doing we
just need to do it now because
people's lives are being hurt how do you
guys see everything that's going on
impacting your own lives and your own
career like is this influencing the
the roles you're going after the things
that you'll say yes to
the products that you promote uh you
know how are you
i guess using your platforms to really
propel asian talent and stories forward
you know it's it's funny because um
it just makes it feel like the need is
is is happening right now like i i say
that
there were you know i used to i used to
think oh it would be nice
when we can have leads and
three-dimensional characters and whole
families of asian descent
for the general uh public it's not a
nice to have
it's a must to have it feels very
present like right now like you speaking
both of you margaret and jeannie
speaking it just
breaks my heart i mean my i just it it
there's a rawness and so all of that
energy
is um i don't know it's pushing
it's pushing me to feel more and demand
more and expect more
um for myself uh from what we write how
we support each other what we demand
from the people that we work with
and what we want to see
and also oh this is just a little side
thing it's a is a small thing but
education is
important and begin to educate yourself
about asian americans in this country
the tone of aapi coverage mostly focuses
on
stuff that's you know critical or
negative and there are people
in the community trying to change that
uh people like sandra oh you know and so
i wanted to find a space
to really celebrate good work and good
actors and so i wanted to ask you guys
you know who or what are you seeing
in the asian american community it could
be in hollywood outside of hollywood
that gets you excited about the future
i'm just excited in general for
everybody out there all of us here on
this panel
and everybody out there who's standing
up for us i feel like
we do need um whoever that john lewis
that malcolm x that mlk
with the asian community whoever that's
going to be that's going to emerge
i feel like that's kind of like we sort
of need one person to get behind but
we're coming together and i'm really
proud of everyone i think there's
definitely a few people who i
see as everyday heroes um lisa ling is
one of them constantly in the yeah for
sure churning up people's stories and
making sure
she she works tirelessly to make sure
they're amplified
daniel day kim is also a great forefront
that's going in front of congress and
even on we've got a group chat where
he's day in day out i know he's on set i
know he's you know
in between movies and stuff but he's
always checking in to make sure like
what are we all doing on the ground to
make sure that we have our support
um i think gold house is another great
place that has just recently
recognized their a100 and they put out a
beautiful
video about what asian americans have
done to
contribute to society also i think
instagram pages like
next shark is so great um yeah ellen
safan
c-e-s-a-a-n is where i get a lot of the
news coverage around
asian american hate crimes all over so
there's a lot of great people
oh my god she's a reporter she's the one
that puts she's the one that's the og
ones up
where it's so great we are
23 million strong from big cities
to rural towns and i do want to
highlight though something
awesome has just happened which is the
asian american foundation
taft they have already committed 125
million dollars
to protecting and serving our community
in legal
um um legalities in in lawsuits in
in every form of support that we need so
that's something you're going to start
seeing spread around so it's awakening
and
caico to kind of what you said earlier
we need to apply pressure that's why
you're feeling
this emotional surge is we've got to
apply pressure guys
i think what gets me really excited is
um how
much more control we seem to be taking
as a community
um instead of waiting around and and
seeing what is being given to us
it seems like in these past few years
it's become more
imperative for us to have that
confidence to be like you know what
instead of waiting for that thing to be
made i'm gonna go make it myself and i'm
gonna
demand that you know you take this out
of the script and here's why
or this is what you guys should do so
just taking more ownership and more
um just a proactive in in in any aspect
of what we're doing
and i think as a collective um it's it i
think it's
we're really moving in in a uh in a good
direction and in
and especially in light of all these
horrible things that are happening even
seeing you know community members get
together and being like we're gonna
patrol the streets it's just like you
can't wait anymore
and so it's like it is voting and
legislation and all that but just seeing
people being like you know i'm sick of
waiting because waiting doesn't do
anything
so we're gonna go out there and be
proactive on on every front and now
because of social media and all that
it's allowed us you know it seems like
for the first time to really connect
in a way globally and nationally
um so we all feel like it's it's like a
unified kind of
movement going forward exactly what
oscars was saying is that
now we are doing it ourselves and so
once you start writing producing
then you have more control and that's
what i think is so wonderful about you
three
um you know you're writers you know your
comedians you're telling your own
story you and i'm getting chills because
because that's so important and i almost
feel like as an actor i've kind of
you know you know i say other people's
words but even me
i'm saying no i have to say my own words
too now and start to put myself out
there so i'm really happy to be on this
panel with you and i'm happy to see
what's gonna what's coming in the future
it really has been amazing for me to
hear your guys's stories but all to
but to all to see all of us together as
well so i just can't thank you enough
for joining us and
being so open and again sharing your
personal experiences i think this
perhaps will be one of my most important
interviews ever so thank you guys all so
much for being so open
thank you for leading this day thank you
[Music]